[Music]
[Applause]
as this ever happened to you you're
visiting Los Angeles to attend a
television taping so you can forget
about your problems for an hour when
without warning you're forced to touch
the nipple of a late night house in
front of your stunned family
hello I'm attorney Alexander gerd of the
law firm of GERD and GERD here to tell
you that if you suffered mental trauma
and emotional distress as a result of
being forced into touching Conan
O'Brien's nipple on national television
you may be entitled to compensation
damages may include depression and
feelings of worthlessness nightmares and
an irrational inability to ring the
doorbell adjust the thermostat use the
soap dispenser engage you for play with
your wife eat cupcakes from an erotic
bakery retaliate during a nuclear war or
touch dr. Phil's nipple and a dirty GERD
we also handle cases involving neural
damage due to prolonged and continuous
exposure to Conan O'Brien Plus girding
dirt will fight for you if you've
suffered injury due to defective coating
t-shirts : sweatshirt and Konan hood in
onesies and even if you've suffered no
injuries at all but are willing to lie
about it you may still be entitled to a
settlement GERD and GERD with offices in
El Segundo la segunda and Flint Michigan
so call today and join the hundreds of
plaintiffs who are trying to reclaim
their lives call now
[Applause]
[Music]
you